I heard Benji got stopped by security so
the guys at the hotel er at the hotel
bar and then this is last night and I
heard Benji came down in full workout
clothes like at the bar at the bar with
headphones and it started to jog around
the bar telling people he was getting
his cardio the [ __ ] is wrong ran out the
door and went around at the front of the
hotel ran back Ian Benji and then
security came and took you why do you
not know what to do when you walk yeah
we only rehearsed this by walked in all
confused where's your where's my
headphones he doesn't know anything
so you were doing shtick at the bar last
night
no security stopped me buddy I heard
Yuri told you to stop I told you stop
that's not true
what is it so we're gonna go Sal has
more insight on he was running around
jogging around the bar right hotel why
are you doing that why would you do that
why won't you just go outside and run
like why do you have to go to the bar
and run around the bar that was fun to
me and I I want I was as well
yeah I will annoy people I
but people patrons are at the bar you
know it's we're not on the air you don't
have to run around the bar in full
workout clothes in full workout clothes
corny well I don't know everyone seems
to feel I understand we don't know what
you were wearing I know what I was what
were you wearing uh I was in what was he
wearing style he was wearing that are
you sure large hat t-shirt and shorts
sweats that's a workout outfit I mean
everything with you I didn't do that but
you did do it
alright thanks thanks for being well
chill and welcome telly
bye